This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Longtime 99PI listeners know that every couple of years, one of our producers breaks off from the normal show production and helms their own mini-series. This is how Avery Truffleman's Articles of Interest and Katie Mingle's According to Need were made, and they represent some of the best work we've ever done. Next week, we will premiere a new series of six episodes that will run twice a week on Tuesdays and Fridays.
这里是 99%无形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。99PI 的老听众都知道，每隔几年，我们的一位制作人就会脱离常规的节目制作，负责制作他们自己的迷你剧。Avery Truffleman 的《兴趣文章》和 Katie Mingle 的《根据需求》就是这样制作出来的，它们代表了我们做过的最好的一些工作。下周，我们将首播一个包含六集的新系列，每周二和周五播出两次。
It was created by longtime superstar producer, Emmett Fitzgerald, and it's called Not Built For This. It is absolutely brilliant. I cannot wait for you to hear it. Here is a preview. I grew up in Vermont, a state that has occasionally been described as a climate haven. Whenever someone publishes a list of places you should move if you want to escape climate change, Vermont always seems to be somewhere near the top.
它是由资深超级明星制作人埃米特·菲茨杰拉德创作的，名为《不为此而生》。它绝对是精彩绝伦。我迫不及待地想让你们听到它。这是一个预告片。我在佛蒙特州长大，这个州有时被描述为气候避难所。每当有人发布一份列出如果你想逃离气候变化应该搬去的地方的名单时，佛蒙特州似乎总是排在靠前的位置。
I've been covering climate change long enough to know that no place will be safe, but I have to admit that I've always found these lists weirdly comforting. That is, until last summer. About a year ago, it rained so hard in central Vermont that my little green valley filled up like a bathtub, flooding downtown Montpelier. This eerie orchestra that you're hearing is the sound of every security system on Main Street going off all at once. It felt almost two on the nose, like the universe was ringing some kind of planetary alarm bell,
我报道气候变化的时间已经够长了，深知没有任何地方是安全的，但我不得不承认，我一直觉得这些名单有一种奇怪的安慰作用。也就是说，直到去年夏天。大约一年前，佛蒙特州中部下了一场大雨，以至于我那片绿色的幽谷像浴缸一样被灌满了水，将蒙彼利埃市中心淹了。你听到的这种诡异的管弦乐声，是主街上所有安全系统同时拉响的声音。这感觉几乎太直接了，就像宇宙在敲响某种星球警报器一样，
saying, snap out of it. Your quaint little home isn't as safe as you think. But if my little town isn't safe, is anyone's? I'm Emmett Fitzgerald, and I'm the host of Not Built For This, a new mini-series from 99% Invisible. And it's about climate change, but it's really about how the complex systems that govern our lives were not designed to handle the tectonic changes that are coming.
仿佛在说，清醒点吧。你那古朴的小窝并没有你想象的那么安全。但是，如果我的小镇都不安全，还有谁的安全是有保障的呢？我是埃米特·菲茨杰拉德，我是《不为此而生》的主持人，这是来自 99%无形的新迷你剧。它是关于气候变化的，但实际上是关于那些支配我们生活的复杂系统是如何被设计得无法应对即将到来的地壳板块般的变化的。
We're going to look at infrastructure and insurance, housing and land use policy, migration and public health. We'll meet people leaving the places they love. When that fire hit, all of a sudden it came clear to me, oh my God, we are in it, this is it, this is climate change, this is what's going to happen. It just kind of came roaring up to my back door. Arriving in places that aren't ready to receive them. And I roughly did the math somewhere between 35, 45,000 people have been displaced.
我们将探讨基础设施和保险、住房和土地使用政策、人口迁移和公共卫生。我们会遇到那些离开他们所爱之地的人们。当那场火灾袭来时，突然之间我明白了，哦天哪，我们深陷其中，就是这样，这就是气候变化，这就是将要发生的事情。它简直是咆哮着来到我的后门。来到了那些还没准备好接纳它们的地点。我粗略地算了一下，大约有 35,000 到 45,000 人流离失所。
I burst into tears. And trying to plan for a turbulent future that they can only vaguely make out. All of us were kind of like, my goodness, well, this would be not ideal. This is a series about how we prepare for the extremely bumpy ride ahead of us. Because right now, we're all living in a world that was just not built for this. How you gonna keep telling them it's a freaking 100-year flood? Well, God dang it. 100 years coming every six months. Straight up.
我失声痛哭。并试图为一个他们只能隐约看清的动荡未来做规划。我们所有人都觉得，天哪，好吧，这可真不理想。这是一个关于我们如何为前方极其颠簸的旅程做准备的系列节目。因为现在，我们都生活在一个根本不为此而生的世界里。你打算怎么继续告诉他们这是一场百年一遇的洪灾？好吧，该死的。每六个月就来一次百年一遇。直截了当地说。
It's called you guys infrastructure is horrible. Coming August 20th from 99% Invisible. Emmett Fitzgerald's not built for this. Get excited. You are going to love it. In addition to Emmett's series, which has been in the works for a couple of years, another side project of mine has restarted and is now in regular production. It's called What Roman Mars Can Learn About Con Law. So, several years ago, when Trump was first elected, there was all this news about the norms and traditions
这就叫你们的基础设施太糟糕了。8 月 20 日由 99%无形为您呈现。埃米特·菲茨杰拉德的《不为此而生》。兴奋起来吧。你们会爱上它的。除了埃米特制作了几年之久的这个系列节目之外，我的另一个副业也重新启动了，现在正在常规制作中。它叫作《罗曼·马尔斯能从宪法诉讼中学到什么》。所以，几年前，当特朗普首次当选时，有各种关于规范和传统的新闻，
he was violating on a regular basis, with people emphatically arguing that he was regularly violating the Constitution. Suddenly obscure clauses like the Emoluments Clause and heretivore never considered hypothetical scenarios were routinely being discussed. Like, can presidents pardon themselves with a tweet? The answer is probably yes, but only for federal crimes.
他经常违反这些规范和传统，人们坚决认为他经常违反宪法。突然之间，诸如薪酬条款之类的晦涩难懂的条款以及以前从未考虑过的假设性情景被例行讨论。比如，总统可以用推特对自己进行特赦吗？答案可能是可以，但仅限于联邦罪行。
My anxiety led me to seek the counsel of my friend and neighbor Elizabeth Cho, who is a law professor at UC Davis. Over the course of 80 episodes, she's taught me so much by taking something from current events and springboarding off of that to teach me US constitutional law. I love the show. Talking to her is one of my favorite things to do. And I also think the podcast itself is a real service to the world. It really grounds me and helps me make sense of everything.
我的焦虑促使我寻求我的朋友兼邻居伊丽莎白·周的建议，她是加州大学戴维斯分校的法学教授。在 80 集的节目中，她通过从时事中取材并以此为跳板来教我美国宪法，这让我学到了很多。我非常喜欢这个节目。和她聊天是我最喜欢的事情之一。而且我也认为播客本身对世界来说是一种真正的服务。它真正让我脚踏实地，并帮助我理解这一切。
We had a very busy first part of the year. I was spending a lot of time with Power Broker and the Con Law podcast went fallow. But there was so much going on in the world and so many confounding Supreme Court decisions, we decided to relaunch it anew and reintroduce it to the curious and beautiful nerds in the 99PI audience. Here are a couple of recent episodes. This one is brand new, getting its world premiere right here. Enjoy. So today is Thursday, August 8th at about 11 a.m. What are we gonna be talking about? All right, well, let's go back to 1960.
我们今年上半年的工作非常繁忙。我花了很多时间在《权力的代理人》上，宪法诉讼播客也因此荒废了。但世界上发生了那么多事情，有那么多令人困惑的最高法院裁决，我们决定重新推出它，并将其重新介绍给 99PI 听众中的那些充满好奇心且可爱的书呆子们。这里有几个最近的节目。这一集是全新的，在这里进行全球首播。好好享受吧。所以今天是 8 月 8 日星期四，大约上午 11 点。我们要聊些什么呢？好的，那么，让我们回到 1960 年。
Okay. On a cold night in February, two officers from the Los Angeles Police Department pulled over a green 1947 Nash driven by Charles Banks. Now Charles was sitting in the front with his wife Norma and in the back seat sat 25 year old Lawrence Robinson, a black army veteran. He was sitting with a lady friend of his. Now the police officers didn't observe any criminal acts from the four people, but they did order Robinson to roll up his sleeves. And the police later testified that they saw what appeared to be numerous needle marks and a scab on his arms.
好的。在一个寒冷的二月份夜晚，两名洛杉矶警察拦下了一辆由查尔斯·班克斯驾驶的绿色 1947 年产纳什汽车。查尔斯和他的妻子诺玛坐在前排，后座上坐着 25 岁的劳伦斯·罗宾逊，一名黑人退伍军人。他和他的一位女性朋友坐在一起。警察没有观察到这四个人有任何犯罪行为，但他们确实命令罗宾逊卷起袖子。警察后来作证说，他们看到罗宾逊的手臂上有看似无数的针孔和伤疤。
And Robinson admitted that he'd used narcotics two weeks before. But it was those needle marks that led to Robinson's arrest. And in June of 1960, a jury convicted Robinson for violating the state's health and safety code. California made it a crime, a misdemeanor, to be addicted to the use of narcotics. And the judge had instructed the jury that they could find Robinson guilty if they agreed that he held the status of being a narcotics user. And Robinson was then convicted and sentenced to 90 days in jail. But he appealed
罗宾逊承认他在两周前使用过麻醉品。但正是这些针孔导致了罗宾逊被捕。1960 年 6 月，陪审团裁定罗宾逊违反了州的健康和安全法。加利福尼亚州将对麻醉品的成瘾行为定为犯罪，即轻罪。法官指示陪审团，如果他们同意罗宾逊拥有麻醉品使用者的身份，他们就可以判定罗宾逊有罪。随后，罗宾逊被定罪并被判处 90 天监禁。但他对
his conviction all the way to the Supreme Court. And in 1962, the Supreme Court decided that Robinson's conviction was unconstitutional. The court noted that no state would make it a crime to be mentally ill, a leper, or to be afflicted by a venereal disease. And there was no difference with California's law making it a crime to be addicted to narcotics. No state should be able to punish someone for their status, even if that status was drug addiction, because it could be, in the Supreme Court's words,
他的定罪一路申诉到了最高法院。1962 年，最高法院裁定罗宾逊的定罪违宪。法院指出，没有哪个州会将精神病、麻风病或感染性病定为犯罪。这与加州将对麻醉品成瘾定为犯罪的法律没有任何区别。任何州都不应因为一个人的身份而惩罚他们，即使这种身份是药物成瘾，因为用最高法院的话说，这种身份可能是，
contracted innocently or involuntarily. So Robinson's conviction was reversed. On July 25th, 2024, California Governor Gavin Newsom issued an executive order telling state agencies to clear what he called dangerous homeless encampments on state land. Cities and counties in California were encouraged
无意中或非自愿地染上的。因此，罗宾逊的定罪被推翻了。2024 年 7 月 25 日，加州州长加文·纽森发布了一项行政命令，指示州机构清理他所谓的州土地上危险的无家可归者营地。加州的城市和县也被鼓励
to do the same. What's the connection between Lawrence Robinson's arrest and this shift in policy that's emerging not just in California, but many parts of the West Coast? A lot, it turns out, because of the Supreme Court. Time to find out. Let's do it. This is what Roman Mars can learn about con law. An ongoing series of indeterminate length and sporadic release where we look at the vague notion of what is cruel and what is unusual and use it to examine our constitution like we never have before.
采取同样的做法。劳伦斯·罗宾逊的逮捕与不仅在加州而且在西海岸许多地区正在出现的这种政策转变之间有什么联系？事实证明，联系很大，因为最高法院。是时候去弄清楚了。我们开始吧。这就是罗曼·马尔斯能从宪法诉讼中学到什么。一个长度不定、发布零星的持续系列节目，我们在其中审视什么是残酷和什么是不同寻常的模糊概念，并以前所未有的方式用它来审视我们的宪法。
Our music is from Doomcheat Records, our professor and neighbor is Elizabeth Jo, and I'm your fellow student and host, Roman Mars. So Roman, the last Supreme Court term we just saw had many really important cases. Not all of them focused on Trump. So today I thought we'd talk about one of them, a case called Grants Pass. Okay, let's do it. The executive order I just mentioned from Governor Newsom focuses on the problem of homelessness. And of course, homelessness is a very complicated policy problem in the United States. There are so many reasons why people end up on the streets. Drug abuse,
我们的音乐来自杜姆奇特唱片公司，我们的教授兼邻居是伊丽莎白·周，我是你的同学兼主持人罗曼·马尔斯。所以，罗曼，我们刚刚看到的最高法院上一个开庭期有很多非常重要的案件。并非所有案件都集中在特朗普身上。所以今天我想我们来聊聊其中一个案件，一个名为格兰茨帕斯的案件。好的，我们开始吧。我刚才提到的纽森州长的行政命令重点关注无家可归的问题。当然，无家可归在美国是一个非常复杂的政策问题。人们流落街头的原因有很多。吸毒、
housing costs, domestic violence, mental illness, or some combination of those things. And many homeless people end up living together in public places like parks and sidewalks. And the problem keeps growing. The federal government's statistics say that homelessness has reached its highest level since it started keeping track in 2007. And homeless encampments became an especially big problem
住房成本、家庭暴力、精神疾病，或者这些因素的某种组合。许多无家可归的人最终聚集在公园和人行道等公共场所生活。而且这个问题还在不断恶化。联邦政府的统计数据显示，无家可归人数已达到自 2007 年开始追踪以来的最高水平。并且无家可归者营地成了一个特别大的问题，
when the pandemic started. In 2020, the Centers for Disease Control issued official guidance about this. They told cities not to break up homeless encampments because it could lead to further spread of COVID-19. And at the same time, many cities also saw residents and businesses leave their downtowns during the worst of the pandemic. Many cities have recovered, but many have not. And the homelessness crisis has gotten worse.
大流行爆发时尤其如此。2020 年，疾病控制与预防中心就此发布了官方指导意见。他们告诉城市不要拆散无家可归者营地，因为这可能导致新冠肺炎的进一步传播。与此同时，在疫情最严重的时候，许多城市的居民和企业也离开了市中心。许多城市已经恢复，但许多城市没有。无家可归危机变得更加严重。
This is a serious public policy problem, an urban planning problem, especially on the West Coast. Again, according to the federal government, more than 40% of the country's homeless population lives in the Western United States. And according to one estimate, there are 70,000 homeless people in the city of Los Angeles alone. So that's the policy issue.
这是一个严重的公共政策问题，一个城市规划问题，尤其是在西海岸。同样根据联邦政府的数据，该国超过 40% 的无家可归人口居住在美国西部。根据一项估计，仅在洛杉矶市就有 70,000 名无家可归者。这就是政策问题。
How do you encourage urban revival after the pandemic when people's habits have changed and when there are large homeless encampments? And how do you help these thousands of people with complicated problems? So one method is to clear out these encampments. Most cities have laws that ban sleeping on the sidewalks or camping in public places.
当人们的习惯发生改变且存在大量无家可归者营地时，你如何在大流行后鼓励城市复苏？你如何帮助这数千名面临复杂问题的人？一种方法是清理这些营地。大多数城市都有法律禁止在人行道上睡觉或在公共场所露营。
What is officially camping in a public place? A law might say that you can't camp on public property, and then camping might be defined as something like setting up a campsite which is any place where bedding, sleeping bags, or other material used for bedding purposes, or any stove or fire is placed for the purpose of maintaining a temporary place to live. So a city could use this kind of law, which might impose fines or even jail time, as an incentive to persuade people living in these encampments to leave,
官方所指的在公共场所露营是什么？一项法律可能会说你不能在公共财产上露营，然后露营可能会被定义为诸如搭建营地之类的事情，营地是指放置被褥、睡袋或其他用作被褥的材料，或者为了维持临时居住地而放置任何炉灶或火源的任何地方。因此，城市可以使用这种可能会处以罚款甚至监禁的法律，作为一种激励措施，来说服居住在这些营地的人离开，
to accept social services, or to accept offers of shelter. So the idea is leave or else. And many cities have adopted a kind of multi-step process to clear these encampments. They might say, look, in 48 hours, we're going to clear the encampments. We're going to have city workers offer social services and shelter, and we're going to help you bag up your things so they're not lost or
接受社会服务，或接受收容所提供的帮助。所以这个想法就是不走就得怎样。许多城市已经采取了一种多步骤的过程来清理这些营地。他们可能会说，听着，在 48 小时内，我们要清理营地。我们将让城市工作人员提供社会服务和收容所，我们将帮你们把东西装进袋子里，这样它们就不会丢失或
stolen. But in other cities, clearing encampment just means heading directly to enforcing these anti-camping laws and arresting people. So Roman sounds like an easy solution to an easy problem. I mean, yeah, it's terrible. It's not an easy problem. There are no easy solutions except for giving people houses, which is, you know, it's a simple solution, but it's complicated in how you enact it. Yeah, and so all of the cities, especially on the West Coast, have struggled with what to do.
被偷。但在其他城市，清理营地只意味着直接开始执行这些反露营法律并逮捕人们。所以，罗曼，这听起来像是解决一个简单问题的一个简单方案。我的意思是，是的，这太糟糕了。这不是一个简单的问题。除了给人房子住之外，没有简单的解决方案，你知道，这是一个简单的解决方案，但你在实施时却很复杂。是的，所以所有的城市，尤其是西海岸的城市，都在为该怎么做而苦恼。
One of those cities is Grants Pass. And Grants Pass is a small town in southwestern Oregon with a population of about 38,000. And Grants Pass has an small town in southwestern Oregon with a population of about 38,000. And Grants Pass has an anti-camping law, like the one I've just mentioned. And the city decided to enforce this law against its homeless population. There are about 600 homeless people there. So it's large for the amount of people who live in the city. The first violation results in a fine fine and then later citations can eventually
其中一个城市就是格兰茨帕斯。格兰茨帕斯是俄勒冈州西南部的一个小镇，人口约 38,000 人。格兰茨帕斯是俄勒冈州西南部的一个小镇，人口约 38,000 人。格兰茨帕斯有一项反露营法，就像我刚才提到的一样。该市决定针对其无家可归人口执行这项法律。那里大约有 600 名无家可归者。所以对于居住在该市的人口数量来说，这个比例很大。第一次违规会导致罚款，然后随后的传票最终可能
lead to people being arrested and eventually jail time. Now, Grants Pass had been relying on these laws pretty aggressively for at least five years when a group of homeless people filed a lawsuit in federal court against the city in 2018. So what was the basis of their lawsuit? Well, the plaintiffs in Grants Pass had a very good chance of winning their case when they filed it. And that was because the Ninth Circuit, that's the federal appeals court covering the West Coast, had decided a very similar case just six weeks before. Yeah, that's the Idaho one, right?
导致人们被捕并最终入狱。现在，格兰茨帕斯已经相当积极地依赖这些法律至少五年了，当时一群无家可归的人于 2018 年在联邦法院对该市提起了诉讼。那么他们诉讼的基础是什么呢？嗯，格兰茨帕斯的原告在起诉时赢得官司的机会非常大。这是因为第九巡回法院，也就是负责西海岸的联邦上诉法院，在仅仅六周前刚裁决了一个非常相似的案件。对，就是爱达荷州那个，对吧？
Yeah, that's right. That earlier case was called Martin vs. City of Boise. And the Martin case also involved a lawsuit brought by a group of homeless people in Boise that challenged that city's enforcement of its anti-camping laws. Just like in Grant's Pass, it's a crime to camp in public spaces in the city of Boise. Now, Boise did have emergency shelters for the homeless,
对，没错。那个早期的案件被称为马丁诉博伊西市案。马丁案也涉及由博伊西一群无家可归的人提起的诉讼，该诉讼挑战了该市对其反露营法的执行。就像在格兰茨帕斯一样，在博伊西市，在公共空间露营是犯罪行为。现在，博伊西确实为无家可归者设有紧急收容所，
but there was not enough bed space for everybody who needed a bed on any given night. And in the Martin case, the plaintiffs argued that arresting the homeless for anti-camping laws violated their constitutional rights. They relied primarily on the case of Lawrence Robinson. So can you see the analogy they're making here? Well, like in Robinson, So can you see the analogy they're making here? Well, like in Robinson, being homeless is not a thing that they can necessarily control. Therefore, being punished for it is cruel and unusual.
但在任何给定的夜晚，都没有足够的床位供所有需要床位的人使用。在马丁案中，原告辩称，因违反反露营法而逮捕无家可归者侵犯了他们的宪法权利。他们主要依据的是劳伦斯·罗宾逊案。那么，你能看出他们这里所做的类比吗？嗯，就像在罗宾逊案中一样，那么，你能看出他们这里所做的类比吗？嗯，就像在罗宾逊案中一样，无家可归并不是他们必然能控制的事情。因此，因此，因此，因此，因
That's exactly right. I mean, remember in Robinson, the Supreme Court said, look, this is about the state trying to punish somebody for their status, who they are, and you can't do that. And in Robinson's case, the Supreme Court specifically said in 1962 that if you criminalize the status of being an addict, that violates the Eighth Amendment. So Roman, why don't you read the amendment?
此，因因此，因因此，因因此，因此，因因此，因因此，因因此，因因此，因为此受到惩罚是残酷和不同寻常的。完全正确。我的意思是，记住在罗宾逊案中，最高法院说，看，这是关于国家试图因为某人的身份、他是谁而惩罚某人，而你不能那样做。在罗宾逊的案件中，最高法院在 1962 年明确表示，如果你将成瘾者的身份定为犯罪，那就违反了第八修正案。那么罗曼，你为什么不读一下这个修正案呢？
Oh, yes. I love this part. Excessive bail shall not be required, nor excessive fines imposed, nor cruel and unusual punishments inflicted. Now in Lawrence Robinson's case, the Supreme Court said that enforcing this addiction law violated his Eighth Amendment right to be free from cruel and unusual punishment. Now this ban on cruel and unusual punishments is a pretty colorful but not very clear phrase.
哦，是的。我喜欢这一部分。不得要求过多的保释金，不得处以过重的罚款，也不得施加残酷和不同寻常的惩罚。现在在劳伦斯·罗宾逊的案件中，最高法院表示，执行这项成瘾法侵犯了他免受残酷和不同寻常惩罚的第八修正案权利。现在，对残酷和不同寻常惩罚的这种禁止是一个相当生动但不算非常清晰的短语。
So what exactly does that mean? Well, it's not, you don't really have a ready answer for every situation. The death penalty, for instance, is a form of punishment that in general is not considered unconstitutional. But there's so many other kinds of things that are punishments. Justice Gorsuch has said that 18th century methods like disemboweling, quartering, public dissection and burning alive would surely be considered cruel and unusual under the Constitution. That's not too helpful either because Robinson's conviction is not similar to any of these
那么这到底意味着什么呢？嗯，它不是，对于每一种情况，你其实都没有现成的答案。例如，死刑是一种普遍不被认为违宪的惩罚形式。但还有那么多其他各种各样的惩罚。戈萨奇大法官曾表示，18 世纪的方法，如开膛破肚、五马分尸、公开解剖和活活烧死，在宪法下肯定会被认为是残酷和不同寻常的。这也没有太大帮助，因为罗宾逊的定罪与这些中的任何一个都不相似
things. And in fact, the court in Robinson's case didn't object to the method of his punishment. Remember, he just got a 90-day jail sentence. Instead, the court said criminalizing his status violated the eighth amendment. So really they're saying that the very idea of making this a crime is what is unconstitutional. So Robinson versus California is an unusual case because of the way in which it's decided. And the Supreme court hasn't shown much interest in developing this idea further after Robinson's
事情。事实上，罗宾逊案中的法院并不反对他的惩罚方式。记住，他只被判处了 90 天的监禁。相反，法院表示，将他的身份定为犯罪违反了第八修正案。所以实际上他们是在说，将这定为犯罪的想法本身就是违宪的。因此，加利福尼亚诉罗宾逊案是一个不同寻常的案件，因为它的裁决方式。在罗宾逊案之后，最高法院并没有表现出对进一步发展这一概念的太大兴趣
case. But it remains a Supreme Court decision. And it is Robinson versus California that the federal appeals court relied on in the Martin case to decide that the city of Boise could not constitutionally enforce its camping law in a specific situation when there are more homeless people than beds available in shelters. So that gives Boise two options. Either you stop enforcing your anti-camping law
案件。但它仍然是最高法院的一项裁决。联邦上诉法院在马丁案中正是依据加利福尼亚诉罗宾逊案，裁定博伊西市在某种特定情况下——即收容所里的无家可归人数多于可用床位时——无权合宪地执行其露营法。这给博伊西留下了两种选择。要么你在这些条件下停止执行你的反露营法，
under these conditions or increase the number of shelter beds so every homeless person could get off of the streets. Those are hard options for any city. And the idea here is that if you are punishing someone for sleeping outside, but there's no other place for them to go, then that is cruel. Like, what are they leaning on in this, you know? I think you've gotten to the core of it, that if you have nowhere to go because there's
或者增加收容所的床位数量，让每个无家可归的人都能离开街道。对于任何城市来说，这些都是艰难的选择。这里的想法是，如果你因为某人在外面睡觉而惩罚他，但他们又没有其他地方可去，那么这确实是残酷的。就像，他们在这其中倾向于什么呢？我想你已经切中了要害，如果你无处可去，因为
no available shelter beds, how can the state punish you? Because you're there involuntarily. You're sleeping on the street through no choice of your own. I'm just trying to find what word in this amendment they're latching onto, you know, that it's particularly cruel, that it's unusual, that it's excessive. You know what you mean?
没有可用的收容所床位，国家怎么能惩罚你呢？因为你在那里是非自愿的。你睡在街上并不是出于你自己的选择。我只是想找出这个修正案中的哪个词是他们所紧抓不放的，你知道的，即它是特别残酷的，它是不同寻常的，它是过度的。你知道我的意思吗？
I don't know. Well, they're not. That's kind of the problem. They're relying on the 1962 case, that's Robinson versus California, where the Supreme Court in that case said, well, it's cruel and unusual to punish someone for their status. And so the Ninth Circuit says, well, this is also punishing someone for their status of being involuntarily homeless.
我不知道。嗯，他们没有。这正是问题所在。他们依赖的是 1962 年的那个案件，即加利福尼亚诉罗宾逊案，最高法院在那个案件中表示，嗯，因为某人的身份而惩罚他是残酷和不同寻常的。因此，第九巡回法院说，嗯，这也是因为某人非自愿无家可归的身份而惩罚他。
So it's building on an argument. So they're really focusing on the idea of status established in that other case, not necessarily on what's being spoken in the amendment itself. Exactly. And so the appeals court is not saying that homeless people have the right to particular beds or that any city has to guarantee beds to people. Really what they're saying is that if the city is going to arrest folks for these anti-camping laws or sleeping on the sidewalk, they have to have this realistic choice of having a shelter bed available. You don't have the choice of a particular bed or a particular shelter, but you have
所以它是在一个论点的基础上建立起来的。因此，他们真正关注的是在另一个案件中确立的身份概念，而不一定关注修正案本身所说的话。完全正确。因此，上诉法院并不是说无家可归的人有权获得特定的床位，也不是说任何城市必须向人们保证床位。他们真正要说的是，如果城市要因为这些反露营法或在人行道上睡觉而逮捕人们，他们就必须具备拥有可用收容所床位的这种现实选择。你没有选择特定床位或特定收容所的权利，但你必须
to have some access to a shelter. The Martin case is a huge decision. It sets the law for all of the West Coast states. Now let's go back to Grants Pass. Okay. The Grants Pass case was filed because of the Martin decision, and it goes a little bit farther. The federal court decided that every homeless person was involuntarily homeless
对收容所有某种程度的使用权。马丁案是一项重大的裁决。它为西海岸的所有州设定了法律。现在让我们回到格兰茨帕斯。好的。格兰茨帕斯案是因为马丁案而提起的，而且它走得更远一点。联邦法院裁定，每一个无家可归的人都是非自愿无家可归的，
because there were not enough shelter beds for the entire population. The Eighth Amendment and Lawrence Robinson's case did not allow the city of Grants Pass to enforce its camping ordinance. So we've just talked about two cities, Boise and Grants Pass, but after the Martin decision, there was a lot of uncertainty and confusion about whether and how cities and counties on the West Coast could enforce their laws and clear these homeless encampments or maybe they couldn't at all. So after these cases, there were many, many lawsuits filed and many judges imposed injunctions or judicially ordered pauses on the enforcement of anti-camping laws in places like San Francisco
因为全人口的收容所床位根本不够。第八修正案和劳伦斯·罗宾逊的案件不允许格兰茨帕斯市执行其露营条例。我们刚刚讨论了两个城市，博伊西和格兰茨帕斯，但在马丁案之后，对于西海岸的城市和县是否以及如何能够执行其法律并清理这些无家可归者营地，或者也许它们根本做不到，存在着许多不确定性和混乱。因此，在这些案件之后，提起了非常非常多的诉讼，许多法官对诸如旧金山等地执行反露营法的行为实施了禁令或司法下令的暂停，
and Los Angeles. But the problem was that each time there were small variations about what counted as an available shelter or an adequate shelter so that cities could enforce their laws in ways that didn't violate the Eighth Amendment. So, for instance, in 2020, a federal judge said that adequate shelters meant that shelters needed certain features like nursing staff who could provide COVID tests and on-site security. In 2022, a federal judge
和洛杉矶。但问题是，每次对于什么算作可用收容所或充足收容所，都存在微小的差异，以便城市能够以不违反第八修正案的方式执行其法律。例如，在 2020 年，一名联邦法官表示，充足的收容所意味着收容所需要具备某些功能，例如能够提供新冠检测的护士人员和现场保安。2022 年，一名联邦法官
ordered the city of San Francisco not to enforce its anti-camping laws, but the decision left unclear how the city was supposed to determine who was involuntarily homeless and who was not on a daily basis. And you can imagine that's hard to do, right? Not everyone cooperates. It's not clear who really has access to a shelter, or who doesn't.
下令旧金山市不得执行其反露营法，但该裁决并未明确该市应该如何每天确定谁是非自愿无家可归者，谁不是。你可以想象这很难做到，对吧？并非每个人都配合。目前还不清楚谁真正有权使用收容所，谁没有。
Yeah. And I don't even know if I know how to define who a voluntarily homeless person is. I mean. That's right. That's right. It's really hard to do. So these decisions raise a very simple question, right?
是的。我甚至不知道自己是否知道如何定义谁是自愿无家可归的人。我的意思是。没错。没错。这确实很难做到。所以这些决定提出了一个非常简单的问题，对吧？
Do these people have the right to be here? But the answers from all of these different courts were complex, sometimes somewhat inconsistent, and very hard for cities and counties to comply with. So it was no surprise that the Supreme Court decided to review the case of Grants Pass. And the Supreme Court issued its decision in Grants Pass versus Johnson on June 28th, right at the end of its term. Now, before the Supreme Court takes up its case, I want to just pause for a moment on the issue itself.
这些人有权留在这里吗？但所有这些不同法院的答案都很复杂，有时有些不一致，并且对城市和县来说非常难以遵守。因此，最高法院决定审查格兰茨帕斯案也就不足为奇了。最高法院在 6 月 28 日，也就是其开庭期即将结束时，对格兰茨帕斯诉约翰逊案作出了裁决。现在，在最高法院审理此案之前，我想先就这个问题本身暂停一下。
The politics of this issue are pretty complicated, don't you think? Yeah, because as you stated, the most intense pressure when it comes to homelessness and interacting with communities is in the West where there's a lot of liberal folks who run things who want to take care of the homeless, but also know that this is not a thing that is tenable if encampments get bigger and bigger and bigger. That's right. And then the folks who are bringing lawsuits are advocates for the homeless or civil rights organizations, also considered progressive or left. So this isn't a kind of neat right-left divide. You have a very complicated set of decisions that have to
这个问题背后的政治非常复杂，你不觉得吗？是的，因为正如你所说，当涉及到无家可归和与社区互动时，压力最大的地方是在西部，那里有很多负责管理事务的自由派人士，他们想要照顾无家可归的人，但也知道如果营地越来越大，这种情况是站不住脚的。没错。然后，提起诉讼的人是无家可归者的倡导者或民权组织，也被认为是进步派或左翼。因此，这并不是那种明确的右翼与左翼的分裂。你必须作出一套非常复杂的决定，
be made, and the alignments are not what you would necessarily expect. And for some of the federal judges, it was a very personal issue. Here's what one federal appeals court judge said in the grants passed lawsuit before the case went to the Supreme Court. This judge said, assume you are a police officer and you encounter a homeless person in some public place, say San Francisco's Civic Center near the James R. Browning building where our court sits. Assume further that the person has set up a tent and engaged in activities like defecation and urination on the sidewalk nearby. Under Martin, you are powerless to cite this person
而且阵营并不一定是你所预期的那样。对于一些联邦法官来说，这是一个非常私人的问题。以下是联邦上诉法院的一位法官在案件上最高法院之前在格兰茨帕斯诉讼中所说的话。这位法官说，假设你是一名警察，你在某个公共场所遇到了一个无家可归的人，比如旧金山市民中心，靠近我们法院所在的詹姆斯·R·勃朗ニング大楼。进一步假设这个人搭起了帐篷，并且在附近的人行道上有排便和排尿等行为。根据马丁案，你无权传唤此人
even for public defecation because San Francisco has fewer shelter beds than total homeless persons. And so in fact, a very large number of cities, states, and counties filed briefs asking, begging the Supreme Court to take the case, not just from the West Coast, but also from places all around the country, because they wanted some clarity on what was permitted and what was not. Now some of these local governments asked the Supreme Court to overturn the Grants Pass case. But others, like California's Governor Newsom,
甚至因为公开排便而传唤，因为旧金山的收容所床位少于无家可归者的总数。因此，事实上，数量非常庞大的城市、州和县提交了意见陈述，要求、乞求最高法院审理此案，不仅来自西海岸，也来自全国各地，因为他们希望对什么是允许的、什么是被禁止的有一些清晰的认识。现在，其中一些地方政府要求最高法院推翻格兰茨帕斯案。但其他人，比如加州州长纽森，
simply filed a brief asking for clarity. He wasn't asking for any side in particular. He just said, please make clear what we can do in ways that are constitutional, respecting the rights of the people in these encampments, but allowing the cities to do something about the problem. So Justice Gorsuch wrote the majority opinion in Grants Pass. And I think you can understand Gorsuch's point of view from just two sentences from the opinion. He says, policymakers need access to the full panoply of tools in the policy toolbox to
只是提交了一份请求明确性的意见陈述。他没有支持任何特定的立场。他只是说，请明确说明我们能以何种符合宪法的方式做些什么，尊重这些营地中人们的权利，但同时允许各城市针对这个问题采取一些行动。因此，戈萨奇大法官撰写了格兰茨帕斯案的多多数意见书。我想你可以从意见书中的短短两句话中理解戈萨奇的观点。他说，政策制定者需要使用政策工具箱中的全套工具来
tackle the complicated issues of housing and homelessness. Five years ago, the US Court of Appeals for the Ninth Circuit took one of those tools off the table. So what's the reasoning behind his opinion? Well there's two major points. In the majority's view, the Eighth Amendment, the one that bans cruel and unusual punishments, has nothing to do with local governments using anti-camping laws as one of its methods to address homeless encampments. Remember, as you pointed out, the Eighth Amendment talks about cruel and unusual punishments.
解决住房和无家可归等复杂问题。五年前，美国第九巡回上诉法院将其中一个工具从桌面上撤下了。那么他意见背后的推理是什么呢？嗯，有两个主要观点。在多数派看来，第八修正案（即禁止残酷和不同寻常惩罚的修正案）与地方政府利用反营地法作为解决无家可归者营地的方法之一没有任何关系。记住，正如你所指出的，第八修正案谈论的是残酷和不同寻常的惩罚。
We typically think of that as what happens after conviction. And the majority in Grants Pass says, well, that's the main focus of the Eighth Amendment. And the problem with the lawsuit in Grants Pass is that it isn't really focused on the punishment at all. It's a lawsuit about the criminal law itself. The punishment afterwards, which could include civil fines, exclusion orders, and then jail sentences, it's just not that severe or strange. It doesn't seem cruel and unusual in the slightest. And so what does this mean for the Robinson case, the addict case?
我们通常认为这是定罪后发生的事情。格兰茨帕斯案的多数派表示，这正是第八修正案的主要焦点。格兰茨帕斯诉讼的问题在于，它根本不是以惩罚为中心的。这是一场关于刑法本身的诉讼。之后的惩罚，可能包括民事罚款、驱逐令以及随后的监禁判决，其实并没有那么严重或奇怪。它一点也不显得残酷和不同寻常。那么这对罗宾逊案（吸毒者案）意味着什么呢？
Well, the people who challenged the anti-camping law in Grants Pass said, look, this is exactly like Lawrence Robinson's case. Robinson was being punished for being an addict, and we're being punished for being homeless. That's unconstitutional. But the majority in Grants Pass has a very simple response to this. Let's take a look at the law.
嗯，那些对格兰茨帕斯的反露营法提出质疑的人说，看，这完全就像劳伦斯·罗宾逊的案子。罗宾逊因为是个瘾君子而受到惩罚，而我们则因为无家可归而受到惩罚。那是违宪的。但格兰茨帕斯的多数派对此有一个非常简单的回应。让我们看看法律是怎么写的。
In Robinson, the state of California had made it a crime to be addicted to the use of narcotics. The law that's challenged in the Grants Pass case says, you can't occupy a campsite on public property for the purpose of maintaining a temporary place to live. Saruman, can you see how these laws might be considered pretty different? Well, they seem entirely different. It's hard to find similarities, actually, in some ways.
在罗宾逊案中，加利福尼亚州将对麻醉品成瘾定为犯罪。格兰茨帕斯案中受到质疑的法律规定，你不能为了维持临时居住地而占用公共财产上的露营地。萨鲁曼，你能看出这些法律在多大程度上被认为是截然不同的吗？嗯，它们看起来完全不同。实际上，在某些方面很难找到相似之处。
I mean, to me, the most obvious one is this kind of nebulous idea of being addicted to something versus the action of actually putting down a bed and a stove and things like that. They just seem like completely different things to be able to measure and control. That's exactly how the majority sees it. The majority in Grants Pass says, look, the law in Robinson's case was punishing the fact that Robinson was an addict, nothing he was actually doing at the time he was arrested.
我的意思是，对我来说，最明显的区别在于沉迷于某物的这种模糊概念与实际放下床铺、炉灶等行为之间的差异。它们看起来像是完全不同的、可以被衡量和控制的事物。这正是多数派所看到的。格兰茨帕斯的多数派表示，看，罗宾逊案中的法律惩罚的是罗宾逊是一个瘾君子这一事实，而不是他在被捕时实际做的任何事情。
But the law in Grant's pass, which is similar to almost every anti-camping law around the country, doesn't focus on the status or the fact of being homeless. They simply state that there are acts that you can't engage in. And that makes all the difference, says the Supreme Court in Grant's pass. And that's why these laws are constitutional. Now, the Supreme Court doesn't overrule Robinson's case. It just says Robinson has nothing to do with these anti-camping laws at all.
但格兰茨帕斯的法律（类似于全国几乎所有的反露营法）并不关注无家可归的身份或事实。它们只是声明有些行为是你不能参与的。最高法院在格兰茨帕斯案中表示，这带来了所有的不同。这就是这些法律合宪的原因。现在，最高法院并没有推翻罗宾逊案。它只是说罗宾逊与这些反露营法完全没有关系。
Interesting. And in fact, the Supreme Court says the Grant's Pass case is much closer to another case it decided shortly after Robinson. It's a case called Powell versus Texas. Leroy Powell had been convicted in Texas of the crime of getting drunk or being found in a state of intoxication in any public place. Powell argued to the Supreme Court that he was just like Lawrence Robinson.
有趣。事实上，最高法院表示，格兰茨帕斯案更接近它在罗宾逊案之后不久裁决的另一个案件。这是一个名为鲍威尔诉德克萨斯州的案件。勒罗伊·鲍威尔在德克萨斯州被判犯有在任何公共场所醉酒或被发现处于醉酒状态的罪行。鲍威尔向最高法院辩称，他就像劳伦斯·罗宾逊一样。
He was an addict. He was an alcoholic. So Texas was punishing him for his status, and that violated his Eighth Amendment rights. But in 1968, just six years after Robinson's case, the Supreme Court decided that even if Powell could not help what he was doing, because he was an alcoholic,
他是一个瘾君子。他是一个酒鬼。因此，德克萨斯州在因为他的身份而惩罚他，这侵犯了他的第八修正案权利。但在 1968 年，即罗宾逊案发生仅六年之后，最高法院裁定，即使鲍威尔因为是个酒鬼而无法控制自己的行为，
Texas was not punishing him for being an alcoholic. Texas was punishing the very specific act of being drunk in public. So a very different case from Robinson's, and so Texas could constitutionally punish Leroy Powell. And so in Gorsuch's view, anti-camping laws are just like that Texas law. Here's what the majority in the Grants Pass case said.
德克萨斯州也不是因为他是个酒鬼而惩罚他。德克萨斯州惩罚的是在公共场合醉酒的非常具体的行为。因此，这是一个与罗宾逊案非常不同的案件，因此德克萨斯州可以合宪地惩罚勒罗伊·鲍威尔。因此，在戈萨奇看来，反露营法就像德克萨斯州的法律一样。格兰茨帕斯案的多数派是这样说的。
The public camping laws prohibit actions undertaken by any person regardless of status. It makes no difference whether the charge defendant is currently a person experiencing homelessness, a backpacker on vacation or a student who abandons his dorm room to camp out in protest on the lawn of a municipal building. So it's sort of like everybody has a right to sleep under the bridges kind of idea. Or everyone doesn't. Or everyone doesn't, right.
公共露营法禁止任何人无论其身份如何而实施的行动。被指控的被告目前是无家可归者、度假的背包客，还是为了抗议而放弃宿舍楼去市政大楼草坪上露营的学生，这没有任何区别。所以这有点像每个人都有权睡在桥底下的想法。或者每个人都没有。或者每个人都没有，对吧。
So the dissenters, of course, did not see any distinction. Justice Sotomayor wrote a dissent that was joined by Justices Kagan and Jackson. And Sotomayor says, look, for some people, sleeping outside is really the only choice they have. And the fact that the anti-camping laws literally punish acts rather than status is not really the point. Sotomayor points out that if we look beyond the literal words,
所以，当然，持不同意见者没有看到任何区别。索托马约尔大法官撰写了一份不同意见书，卡根大法官和杰克逊大法官对此表示赞同。索托马约尔说，看，对某些人来说，睡在外面真的是他们唯一的选择。反露营法字面上惩罚的是行为而不是身份，这其实并不是重点。索托马约尔指出，如果我们超越字面上的词汇，
if we see why these laws were passed, who is enforcing them and what they say when they're enforcing them, we can see they're specifically designed to punish homeless people who happen to be sleeping in the parks or on the sidewalks. These laws are designed to only target the people who don't have a choice to live anywhere else. Nobody else, not the backpacker, not the person who just happens to have a pillow in the park. These are not people who are arrested. And so for Sotomayor, the Grants Pass Law, like all of these other anti-camping laws, are really laws that truly target the status of homelessness. And that's what makes them unconstitutional in the dissenters' mind.
如果我们看看这些法律为什么通过、是谁在执行它们以及他们在执行时说了什么，我们就会发现它们专门旨在惩罚恰好睡在公园或人行道上的无家可归的人。这些法律旨在仅针对那些没有选择在其他任何地方生活的人。没有其他人，不是背包客，也不是碰巧在公园里有枕头的人。这些人并没有被捕。因此，对索托马约尔来说，格兰茨帕斯法就像所有这些其他反露营法一样，实际上是真正针对无家可归身份的法律。持不同意见者认为，正是这一点使它们违宪。
I'm convinced of that. Because we both, I mean, everyone knows that it isn't the backpacker or the young kid, like, that is getting moved off of a public's spot, especially if they're a white young kid. It really is just for homeless people. I think that's right. I think the problem is that because of the way that the court has decided this area of the law, that there's only this one sort of outlier case, Lawrence Robinson's case, and they've never really revisited it.
我对此深信不疑。因为我们俩，我的意思是，每个人都知道被移出公共场所的不是背包客或年轻小伙子，尤其是如果他们是白人年轻小伙子的话。它真的只是针对无家可归的人。我认为这是对的。我认为问题在于，由于法院裁决这一法律领域的方式，只存在这一个异常案件，即劳伦斯·罗宾逊案，而且他们从未真正重新审视过它。
And it means that they never really liked that case ever since. They don't really want to overrule that case. But if we're really going to have a Supreme Court that says, well, if there's a law that punishes acts, what we really need to do is look at how it's enforced to see whether it's punishing status. That would really open up a lot of challenges to every kind of criminal law. Yeah, yeah, sure.
这意味着从那以后他们就再也没有真正喜欢过那个案件。他们真的不想推翻那个案件。但是，如果我们真的要有一个最高法院说，嗯，如果有一部法律惩罚行为，我们真正需要做的是看看它是如何被执行的，以确定它是否在惩罚身份。那真的会引发对各种刑法的许多挑战。是的，是的，当然。
That's not a place where the court wants to go. No. So after the grants passed decision, like what happens now then? Well, what it really means is that state and local governments now are free to enforce their anti-camping laws, anti-sleeping on the sidewalk laws, if they want to use these as tools to clear homeless encampments., if they want to use these as tools to clear homeless encampments. They don't have to enforce these laws,
这不是法院想要去的地方。不。因此，在格兰茨帕斯做出裁决之后，接下来会发生什么呢？嗯，这真正意味着的是，州和地方政府现在可以自由地执行其反露营法、禁止在人行道上睡觉的法律，如果他们想把这些作为清理无家可归者营地的工具的话，如果他们想把这些作为清理无家可归者营地的工具的话。他们不必执行这些法律，
they can really do whatever they want. They can continue to offer shelter and services, they can do nothing if those offers are refused. But after the grants pass case, the decision is left entirely up to cities, counties, and states. They can use persuasion or they can use arrests. And so that's what we're starting to see already.
他们真的可以随心所欲。他们可以继续提供收容所和支援服务，如果这些提议被拒绝，他们也可以什么都不做。但在格兰茨帕斯案之后，这一决定完全由城市、县和州自行决定。他们可以使用说服手段，也可以使用逮捕手段。所以这正是我们已经开始看到的情况。
So in San Francisco, Mayor London Breed has already announced that the city will take more aggressive steps after the grant's passed decision. She's told the city's police officers that they can cite homeless people for illegal camping if they refuse offers of shelter. That was something that they couldn't do before this case.
所以在旧金山，市长伦敦·布里德已经宣布，在该项判决通过后，该市将采取更激进的措施。她告诉该市的警察，如果流浪汉拒绝接受庇护安排，他们可以因非法露营对其进行传唤。这是在此案判决之前他们无法做到的事。
She also announced that police will enforce laws that ban sitting or lying down on sidewalks. I assume that wouldn't be enforced evenly, probably only enforced against people who appear to be homeless. No way would that be enforced evenly. So that's the clear consequence of the Supreme Court stepping in.
她还宣布，警察将开始执行禁止在人行道上坐卧的法律。我猜这不会被公平执行，可能只会针对那些看起来像流浪汉的人。这种法律绝不可能得到公平执行。所以这就是最高法院介入后带来的明显后果。
There's no longer any confusion. It's absolutely clear that each city, state or county can do whatever it likes. There is a separate issue that comes up, I think, not having to do with cruel and unusual punishments. When you think about what it means for cities and counties after grants pass, this is a decision about local governments. But it's also a policing decision, too. Because when you think about the carrot and stick approach
现在已经没有任何混淆了。绝对清楚的是，每个城市、州或县都可以随心所欲地行事。我认为，这里还出现了一个独立的问题，它与残酷及不寻常的惩罚无关。当你思考“格兰茨帕斯案”判决后对城市和县意味着什么时，这是一个关于地方政府的决定。但这也是一个关于警务的决定。因为当你考虑到胡萝卜加大棒的方法时——
that's been used in the case of homeless encampments, well, getting people off the streets is often a matter of incentivizing people or saying, well, the police are going to arrest you. So you can think of grants pass as a Supreme Court incentivizing people or saying, well, the police are going to arrest you. So you can think of grants passed as a Supreme Court case that also grants more powers in the case of policing. Because if the police can enforce these laws, not just anti-camping laws, but laws that
这种方法一直被用于处理流浪汉营地，嗯，让人们离开街头往往关乎提供激励，或者说，警察要逮捕你了。所以你可以把“格兰茨帕斯案”看作是最高法院提供了一种激励，或者说是在发出警告：警察要抓人了。因此，“格兰茨帕斯案”也可以被视为赋予警方更多执法权力的最高法院判决。因为如果警察能够执行这些法律——不仅仅是反露营法，还包括那些——
ban sitting and lying down on sidewalks, they have more tools in general at their disposal. I think one of the problems though is that these laws are notoriously vague and broad, and that means they have the potential to be used in ways that might be considered arbitrary or discriminatory or unevenly enforced. Now this kind of concern doesn't have a place in the cruel and unusual punishments area of the law, but there is some possibility that someone might bring up a claim that, well, maybe these laws are unconstitutionally vague. I can't really understand how to comply with these laws.
禁止在人行道上坐卧的法律——他们手中总体上就有了更多工具。不过我认为其中一个问题在于，这些法律出了名的含糊不清、范围广泛，这意味着它们有可能被以任意、歧视性或执法不公的方式运用。现在，这种担忧在法律中关于残酷和不寻常惩罚的领域并无立足之地，但确实存在某种可能性，即有人会提出这样的主张：也许这些法律因违宪而含糊不清。我实在无法理解如何去遵守这些法律。
And if an ordinary person can't figure out how to avoid violating an ambiguously-ordered law, well, that means that there's a risk that the police could arrest anybody for any reason or maybe no reason at all. I bring this up because Justice Sotomayor, who writes the dissent in Grants Pass, suggested, look, we're just deciding the Eighth Amendment claim here today, but there's some possibility that there could be a due process claim here as well.
如果一个普通人根本搞不懂如何才能避免触犯一条表述含糊不清的法律，这就意味着存在这样一种风险：警察可以出于任何原因、甚至毫无理由地逮捕任何人。我之所以提出这一点，是因为在“格兰茨帕斯案”中撰写不同意见书的大法官索托马约尔暗示说：听着，我们今天只是在裁决第八修正案的诉求，但这里同样存在提出正当程序诉求的某种可能性。
And what does she mean by that? What she means by this is somebody could raise a due process claim that these laws are called void for vagueness. They're unconstitutionally vague and they could be potentially struck down on a different basis. I see. So it's just kind of like raising a little hint to future lawsuits potentially that might be raised.
她这话是什么意思？她的意思是，可能会有人提出正当程序诉求，认为这些法律因“内容空洞含糊”而无效。它们因违宪而含糊不清，并且有可能在不同的法律依据下被推翻。原来如此。这就像是给未来可能提起的诉讼暗中留下了一点暗示。
And how she might rule on those. And let me go back with a coda about Lawrence Robinson. OK. Remember him? Yeah. Robinson was found dead in a Los Angeles alley, probably of an overdose, in August of 1961. That was 10 months before the Supreme Court issued its opinion in his case.
以及她可能会如何对这些诉讼做出裁决。现在让我用一段尾声来谈谈劳伦斯·鲁滨逊。好的。还记得他吗？记得。1961年8月，鲁滨逊被发现死在洛杉矶的一条小巷里，死因很可能是吸毒过量。那是在最高法院对他的案件做出裁决的十个月前。
It's not clear whether Robinson's lawyer was hiding the fact or didn't know that his client had died. Now, then the Supreme Court issued its actual opinion in Robinson v. California in 1962. And after they discovered that Robinson was dead, California's Attorney General asked the Supreme Court to vacate its decision because it was moot, no longer relevant because Robinson was dead. The Supreme Court denied the petition, and California versus Robinson ended up living on as an important opinion, an opinion on the Eighth Amendment that Justice Gorsuch would describe
目前还不清楚鲁滨逊的律师当时是在隐瞒这一事实，还是根本不知道他的当事人已经去世。随后，最高法院于1962年在“鲁滨逊诉加利福尼亚州案”中发布了实际判决。在发现鲁滨逊已死之后，加利福尼亚州总检察长要求最高法院撤销其判决，因为该案已经失效，由于鲁滨逊的死而不再具有相关性。最高法院驳回了这一请求，“加州诉鲁滨逊案”最终得以存留，成为一项重要的判决，一项关于第八修正案的判决，大法官戈尔萨奇在——
in 2024 as a notable exception. Wow. What a story. I mean, this is one of the things that I just like. It only came to the revelation after we started talking. But just like, law school is just stories. It's just so cool. It is stories.
2024年将其描述为一个值得注意的例外。哇。真是个传奇的故事。我的意思是，这就是那些让我觉得……这直到我们开始讨论后才为人所知的事情。但这就好像，法学院里全都是故事。这太酷了。确实都是故事。
Yeah. It's so amazing. I mean, one of the things that's really amazing about constitutional law is, you know, we always hear about these, you know, big name lawyers that argue these cases, but so many of the most important cases start out with the most ordinary kind of situations and ordinary people and through luck and happenstance, their case is the one that becomes the case that is cited for decades.
是的。太惊人了。我的意思是，关于宪法的一个真正令人惊叹的地方在于，你知道的，我们总是听到那些大名鼎鼎的律师在法庭上为这些案件辩护，但许多最重要的案件，最初都是从最普通的境况和最普通的人开始的，由于机缘巧合，他们的案子最终成了几十年来被不断引用的判例。
Yeah, yeah. I am very sympathetic and mostly I'm like on the sort of mayor team on all things and you know I follow her line of thought most of the time. One thing that this does bring to mind though is the nature of policing is there is definitely a bad side for it being discretionary and vague. But there is kind of an upside to that as well, because if the community standard for what the cops do and how we hold our elected officials who control the police in some way responsible, that sentiment could trickle down in a good way too, right? Oh, absolutely. I mean, discretion is not 100% bad.
对，对。我非常赞同，而且大多数时候我在所有事情上都倾向于市长这一边，你知道的，大多数时候我都赞同她的思路。不过，这件事确实让人联想到：执法的一个特质在于，它的自由裁量权和模糊性肯定有不好的一面。但这也算是一种积极的方面，因为如果社区对于警察该做什么，以及我们如何让在某种程度上控制警察的民选官员承担责任有某种共同的标准，这种民意也可以以一种好的方式渗透下来，对吧？哦，绝对是这样。我的意思是，自由裁量权并非百分之百是坏事。
Police discretion can mean that police can be understanding in situations that technically call for a citation or arrest. I mean, we shouldn't think of police discretion as some sort of evil. I think the problem is police discretion only comes up in legal cases and goes up to the Supreme Court when there have been bad uses of discretion, right? When you have police saying that is just targeting a group
警察的自由裁量权意味着，在那些按技术标准需要传唤或逮捕的情况下，警察可以表现得体谅和理解。我的意思是，我们不应该把警察的自由裁量权视为什么洪水猛兽。我认为问题在于，警察的自由裁量权只有在引发法律诉讼并上诉到最高法院时，才会被注意到，而这往往是因为自由裁量权遭到了滥用，对吧？也就是当警察说——
or saying, look, we're just going to arrest these people because they're the unpopular people in the city or the community. And that's if the Supreme Court's ever worried about police discretion, those are the situations where it arises. But you're right. I mean, even with what's happened after grants passed,
或者说：听着，我们要逮捕这些人，因为他们是城市或社区里不受欢迎的人。如果最高法院曾经对警察的自由裁量权感到担忧，那也是在这种情况下发生的。不过你说得对。我的意思是，即便在“格兰茨帕斯案”宣判之后发生的事情中——
there have definitely been cities on the West Coast that reacted to the Supreme Court decision and said, look, that's what they said, but we're not changing our position. We're still going to offer shelter and social services. We're not going to use policing in an aggressive way to punish these folks. So in a way, you might say that this is a decision about sending it back to local communities and deciding what to do. So that leaves a lot in the hands of local folks to decide how they want to address this.
西海岸确实有一些城市对最高法院的判决做出了反应，并表示：听着，那是他们说的，但我们不会改变立场。我们仍将提供庇护和 社会服务。我们不会以激进的方式利用警权来惩罚这些人。所以从某种意义上说，你可能会认为这是一个将权力交回给地方社区去决定该怎么做的判决。因此，这把大量的决定权留给了当地民众，由他们来决定如何应对这一问题。
And that can be using the tools of policing as a backup or using it in the first place. And that's what I think will concern some people. Yeah. I mean, that's what I think will concern some people. Yeah. I mean, the silver lining to this is that placing this back into just the local community and for them to assess their values and really realize what they're doing here
这可以表现为将警务手段作为后盾，或者一开始就直接使用它。而这正是我认为会让某些人感到担忧的地方。对。我的意思是，这就是我认为会让某些人感到担忧的地方。对。我的意思是，这件事的积极意义在于，将其重新放回地方社区层面，让他们去评估自身的价值观，并真正认识到他们在这里所做的事情——
and not kind of rely on whatever, these strictures of law that they feel like their hands are tied. Now they know that they're not. And maybe it causes them to be more charitable. And maybe it causes them to think more holistically about the problem. I would have some hope that the better angels of our nature would come through when they realize that they have this power to really destroy someone's life. And maybe they just choose not to, and that would be really, really great. I hope that's right.
而不是依赖于任何那些让他们感到束手束脚的严苛法律约束。现在他们知道自己并没有被绑住手脚。也许这会促使他们变得更加宽容。也许这会促使他们更全面地思考这个问题。我心存一丝希望，当人们意识到自己拥有真正摧毁一个人一生的权力时，他们人性中善良的天使会占上风。也许他们只是选择不去这么做，那将真的是——太棒了。我希望是这样的。
I mean, I hope that cities go in the way that is in the opposite direction of what we saw in the Grants Pass, which was basically, say, a decision before the lawsuit that we're just going to get rid of these people, and we're just going to start arresting them left and right. And that's not what you want to see. We want to see some other other more humane approach.
我的意思是，我希望各个城市的走向能与我们在“格兰茨帕斯案”中看到的相反。那个案件的基本情况是，在诉讼之前就做出决定，即我们要摆脱这些人，我们要开始左右开弓地逮捕他们。这绝对不是你乐见的结果。我们希望看到其他更有人情味的处理方法。
And hopefully, more communities will adopt that. Yeah. Well, good. I mean, I don't know if I'm extremely hopeful. But at least there's something there for people to take charge of this and for people who are aware of this to know that now they actually have the local control to make those decisions and provide those services
但愿会有更多的社区采纳这种方法。好。好吧，我不确定自己是否抱有极大的希望。但至少，这为人们主导此事提供了一个契机，让意识到这一情况的人知道，现在他们实际上拥有了做出这些决定并提供这些服务的地方控制权——
and solve the problem in a specific way related to that community. I think that, you know, I don't know, we should take on that responsibility. Yeah, that's right. It's definitely back in our hands now. This is fascinating stuff, Elizabeth. Thank you so much.
并以与该社区相关联的具体方式来解决这个问题。我认为，你知道的，我不知道，我们应该承担起这份责任。是的，没错。这绝对又回到了我们手中。这是些迷人的话题，伊丽莎白。非常感谢。
Thanks, Roman. Good to be with you. ["The Time Is Now"] After this, another completely different episode of What Roman Mars Can Learn About Con Law that we released two weeks ago. So we are talking on Thursday, July 25th at about 11 15 a.m. and it has been an incredible week in politics and government. What are we going to talk about this week? Well, you're right.
谢谢你，罗曼。很高兴能和你一起聊这些。《此刻正是时机》之后，我们要播出的是两周前发布的关于“罗曼·马尔斯能从宪法学中学到什么”的另一个完全不同的单集。所以我们是在7月25日星期四上午11点15分左右进行录制的，对于政治和政府来说，这是不可思议的一周。我们本周要聊些什么呢？嗯，你说得对。
I think we just lived through what seems like the longest week of 2024 so far anyway. Yeah, so shall we recount what happened? Yes, let's start there. On July 13th, Trump survived an assassination attempt during a rally in Pennsylvania. Then two days later on the 15th, federal judge Eileen Cannon ordered that criminal charges be dismissed against Trump. Then two days later, President Biden tested positive for COVID and isolated himself. Yeah, forgot about that one.
我想我们刚刚经历的似乎是2024年迄今为止最漫长的一周。是的，那我们要不要回顾一下发生了什么？好的，让我们从头说起。7月13日，特朗普在宾夕法尼亚州的一次集会上遭遇暗杀，并幸存下来。接着两天后的15日，联邦法官艾琳·坎农下令驳回针对特朗普的刑事指控。再过两天，拜登总统的新冠病毒检测呈阳性并开始自我隔离。对，把那事儿给忘了。
That's right. And then on the next day, the 18th, Trump formally accepted his nomination as the Republican nominee at the convention in Milwaukee, Wisconsin. Then on the 21st, Biden announced that he would drop out of the presidential race with less than four months before election day. Remember, he had faced this relentless pressure to drop out after his dismal performance in his debate in June with Trump. And less than an hour after that announcement, Biden then endorsed Vice President Kamala Harris to be the Democratic Party's nominee. So in this very, very long week, two of those events have already raised a bunch of legal questions now that Harris is running for president and Trump's criminal case in Florida has disappeared.
确实如此。然后在第二天，即18日，特朗普在威斯康星州密尔沃基举行的代表大会上正式接受了共和党总统候选人提名。接着在21日，拜登宣布退出总统竞选，距离大选日不到四个月。请记住，在6月份与特朗普的辩论中表现糟糕之后，他一直面临着要求其退选的巨大压力。就在该声明发出不到一个小时后，拜登随即背书副总统卡玛拉·哈里斯成为民主党总统候选人。所以在极其漫长的一周里，随着哈里斯竞选总统以及特朗普在佛罗里达州的刑事案件不复存在，其中两起事件已经引发了一系列法律问题。
So what is happening and what are the consequences? Time to find out. Let's do it. On, on, on, on, on, on, on, on, on. This is what Roman Mars can learn about Con law, an ongoing series of indeterminate length and sporadic releases where we look at the far-fetched arguments challenging Vice President Harris on the ballot for president, and a Florida judge's decision to throw out the classified documents case against former President Donald Trump and use them to examine our Constitution like we never have before. Our music is from Doom Street Records, our professor and neighbor is Elizabeth Jo, and I'm your fellow student and host, Roman
那么现在正发生着什么？后果又是什么？是时候去探究了。我们开始吧。这里是“罗曼·马尔斯能从宪法学中学到什么”，这是一个持续进行的、长度不定且不定期更新的系列节目。在节目中，我们将审视那些旨在阻挠副总统哈里斯获得总统竞选资格的荒谬主张，以及佛罗里达州法官驳回针对前总统唐纳德·特朗普涉密文件案的裁决，并以此为切入点，以前所未有的视角审视我们的宪法。我们的音乐来自末日街唱片公司（Doom Street Records），我们的教授兼邻居是伊丽莎白·乔（Elizabeth Jo），我是你的学友兼主持人，罗曼·马尔斯。
Mars. So now here we are, Kamala Harris is very likely the Democratic nominee in the presidential election. And it looks like she's secured enough informal support from delegates to be the nominee. So what is she going to face? I think some Republican-led lawsuits, but Roman, I don't think they should be taken very seriously. Let me address some of the big ones. First, there is talk of running a court to prevent Harris from getting on the state ballots. And I think the argument here is that it's legally too late for her to be the nominee. This claim, let me be clear, is a loser. Why is that?
所以现在我们看到了，卡玛拉·哈里斯极有可能是民主党在总统大选中的候选人。而且看起来她已经获得了来自党代表们的足够非正式支持，从而能够成为候选人。那么她将面临什么？我认为会有一些由共和党主导的诉讼，但罗曼，我认为这些诉讼不应该被太当回事。让我来谈谈其中几个大的诉讼。首先，有言论称要通过法院来阻止哈里斯进入各州的选票名单。我认为这里的论点是，从法律角度来讲，她成为候选人的时间太迟了。我要明确指出，这种主张必输无疑。为什么这么说？
Let me explain. So first, as far as who the nominee is, that's a matter for the political parties. The national party rules determine how delegates are selected. Now of course, everybody thinks, well, Biden announced he was going to run for reelection earlier, and so delegates were providing their support to him. And unofficially, that was true. But Biden, had he not dropped out, would not have become the official Democratic nominee until he was formally nominated at the Democratic National Convention. And that hasn't taken place yet.
让我来解释一下。首先，至于谁是候选人，这是政党内部的事情。全国党代会的规则决定了代表的产生方式。当然，每个人都会想：嗯，拜登之前宣布要竞选连任，所以代表们是将支持票投给他的。非正式来看，确实如此。但拜登如果不是主动退选的话，也要等到在民主党全国代表大会上被正式提名后，才会成为官方的民主党总统候选人。而那个大会还没有召开呢。
So if we assume that Harris becomes the formal nominee during the convention, then she becomes the party's formal candidate, and there's still plenty of time for her to put her name on the ballot. And so it's up to the states to decide their own rules about listing candidates on the general election ballot for president.
因此，如果我们假设哈里斯在党代会期间成为正式候选人，那么她就成为了该党的正式候选人，而且她把自己的名字印上选票的时间仍然非常充裕。因此，由各州来决定将候选人列入总统大选选票的各自规则。
And there's no state now that has a printed paper ballot before the Democratic National Convention in Chicago. So let's take the example of Iowa, right, which has an early ballot access deadline. So Iowa tells the parties, the political parties to provide the names of their nominees no later than 81 days before election day or August 16th. But Iowa also says that parties with late conventions have another couple of days after they finish. And so since the Democratic National Convention
目前没有任何一个州在芝加哥民主党全国代表大会召开之前就打印好纸质选票。我们就以艾奥瓦州为例吧，对吧？该州设定了较早的选票准入截止日期。艾奥瓦州要求各政党，即各政治党派，必须在大选日前至少81天，即8月16日之前提供其提名人的姓名。但艾奥瓦州也规定，举行晚会（指党代会）的政党在大会结束后还有几天的时间。因此，由于民主党全国代表大会——
starts on August 19th and ends on August 22nd, that means that the Democratic National Convention can provide the name of their nominee pretty late. And so Harris isn't even close to being late to have her name on Iowa's ballots. And actually, even before Biden dropped out, some Trump allies threatened to block Biden from withdrawing from the ballot. That's silly too, for the same reason. He's never, he hasn't been the formal nominee yet.
于8月19日开始，8月22日结束，这意味着民主党全国代表大会可以相当晚才提供其提名人的姓名。所以，哈里斯的名字出现在艾奥瓦州的选票上，根本谈不上迟到。事实上，甚至在拜登退选之前，一些特朗普的盟友就曾威胁要阻止拜登从选票上撤下。这也是荒谬的，原因完全一样。他从来没有、他此前还算不上正式候选人。
Also has like a creepy stalker vibe. You can't quit. Yeah, you can't quit me. Yeah. But like a creepy stalker vibe. You can't quit. Yeah, you can't quit me. Yeah. But anyway, it's pretty ridiculous. So there's no chance that such a lawsuit is going to go anywhere. Second, there may be some Republican campaign funding lawsuits. And the idea behind this type of lawsuit might be that Republicans would sue and to stop Harris from using Biden's campaign funds.
这感觉就像是个阴魂不散的跟踪狂。你甩不掉我。对，你甩不掉我。对。但这就有一种阴魂不散的跟踪狂的感觉。你甩不掉我。对，你甩不掉我。对。不过无论如何，这相当荒谬。所以这样的诉讼没有任何成功的可能。其次，可能会有一些针对共和党竞选资金的诉讼。这类诉讼背后的想法可能是，共和党人会提起诉讼，以阻止哈里斯使用拜登的竞选资金。
But Roman, there's a pretty big problem here. Who was on the Democratic ticket until last week? Biden and Harris. That's right. They were running together. They had one committee. Her name was already on all of the campaign funding paperwork. And so her committee just needed to have amended or changed it
但罗曼，这里有一个相当大的问题。直到上周，谁一直出现在民主党的竞选阵营里？拜登和哈里斯。没错。他们是一起竞选的。他们只有一个委员会。她的名字原本就已经出现在所有的竞选资金文书上了。因此，她的委员会只需要进行修正或更改——
to say, well, she's now running for president as vice president. So she's already on the ticket. It's Harris's money to use. So even if there's some conceivable campaign finance issue, there's another problem in a campaign finance challenge, and that is timing is not on the side of the challenger.
写明她现在是以副总统身份竞选总统。所以她本来就已经在竞选名单上了。这些钱本来就是哈里斯可以使用的。因此，即使存在任何可以想象得到的竞选财务问题，在竞选财务挑战中还存在另一个问题，那就是时间不在挑战者这一边。
A federal court would very likely say, look, if you have a problem with Harris's campaign funding, you have to first go to the Federal Election Commission. And unfortunately, the Federal Election Commission typically takes years to resolve complaints. So any resolution about any problem, real or imagined, about Harris's campaign funding would come long after the 2024 election. And presumably even if there was a violation, she'd have to pay a fine. So that's not going to stop her from being the nominee. And then third is the ugliest lawsuit that somehow Harris is not constitutionally eligible
联邦法院极有可能这样认为：听着，如果你对哈里斯的竞选资金有意见，你必须首先向联邦选举委员会提出。不幸的是，联邦选举委员会通常需要数年时间才能解决投诉。因此，对于哈里斯竞选资金存在的任何真实或假想的问题的裁决，都会在2024年大选很久之后才会出来。而且可以推测，即便真的存在违规行为，她最多也就是交罚款。所以这根本无法阻止她成为候选人。第三个则是最丑陋的诉讼，即荒谬地宣称哈里斯在宪法上不具备担任总统的资格。2020年哈里斯与拜登一起竞选时，特朗普就曾说他听说哈里斯不符合资格。你觉得他为什么会这么说？
to be president. Now in 2020, when Harris was running with Biden, Trump said he heard that Harris doesn't qualify. Why do you think he said that? This is a page out of an older playbook. Right. Just plain old racism. So the constitution requires that the president and vice president be quote natural born citizens. Now, Roman, you know where Harris was born. Yeah, she was born in Oakland, California. Do you want to say your signature line or not?
这完全是老一套的政治伎俩。没错。就是赤裸裸的种族主义。因此，宪法要求总统和副总统必须是所谓的“自然出生公民”（natural born citizens）。罗曼，你知道哈里斯是在哪里出生的。是的，她出生在加利福尼亚州奥克兰。你想说出你的标志性台词还是不说？
I don't know if it's downtown or not, but she was probably born in like, in Alta Bates. Like, I don't know. Anyway, there's no question, she is a natural born citizen of the United States. She was born in California in the United States. Now it's also true that both of her parents were not born in the United States. She was born in California in the United States. Now, it's also true that both of her parents were not born in the United States.
我不知道那是市中心还是别的什么地方，但她大概是在奥尔塔贝茨（Alta Bates）那类地方出生的。我不知道。总之，毫无疑问，她是美国的自然出生公民。她出生在美国加利福尼亚州。现在，同样真实的另一件事是，她的父母双方都不是在美国出生的。她出生在美国加利福尼亚州。现在，同样真实的另一件事是，她的父母双方都不是在美国出生的。
They came to the University of California at Berkeley as students to study. But where Harris's parents were born or their citizenship is totally irrelevant to whether Harris is a natural born citizen. Totally. Besides the obvious racism, where does this crazy idea come from that she's somehow not qualified?
他们是作为学生来到加利福尼亚大学伯克利分校求学的。但是，哈里斯父母出生在哪里，或者他们的国籍是什么，与哈里斯是否是自然出生公民完全无关。毫无疑问。除了显而易见的种族主义外，这种认为她不知为何不符合资格的疯狂想法是从哪儿来的？
Well, you remember our friend, John Eastman. Oh, yes, I do. We had a whole episode on John Eastman. He was the law professor and legal advisor to Trump. And Eastman, of course, concocted this zany theory that Vice President Pence could somehow reject the certified state electors and just decide that Trump had won the 2020 election. It's a crazy idea. And since then, Eastman now faces
嗯，你还记得我们的朋友约翰·伊斯特曼（John Eastman）吗？哦，当然记得。我们有一整集节目专门谈过约翰·伊斯特曼。他是特朗普的法学教授和法律顾问。当然，伊斯特曼炮制了这样一个荒谬的理论：副总统彭斯可以以某种方式拒绝各州认证的选举人票，并径直裁定特朗普赢得了2020年大选。这是一个疯狂的想法。从那以后，伊斯特曼现在面临着——
disbarment and criminal charges. But he has also advanced a different crazy legal theory that because Harris's parents were in the United States on student visas when Harris was born in Oakland, that they were not subject to the jurisdiction of the United States. That's language from the 14th Amendment's birthright citizenship clause. Now, I just want to say and be very plain, this is a totally fringe, total crackpot legal theory, but it hasn't stopped people from bringing it up, people who are Trump supporters. So there you have it, three legal challenges that might be raised against Harris. None of them are likely to go anywhere. Okay.
被取消律师资格和刑事指控。但他还提出了另一种疯狂的法律理论：由于哈里斯在奥克兰出生时，她的父母是以学生签证身份在美国逗留的，因此他们不属于“受美国司法管辖”的人。那是宪法第十四修正案关于出生公民权条款中的措辞。现在，我想说并明确指出，这是一个极其边缘化的、彻头彻尾的荒诞法律理论，但这并没有阻止人们——那些特朗普的支持者们——将其提出来。所以你看，这就是可能针对哈里斯提出的三项法律挑战。它们没有一项有成功的可能。好了。
That's good to know. Okay. So now let's turn to the other big legal news of that very long week, Judge Cannon's decision to dismiss the indictment and Trump's criminal case in Florida. Now, I thought we should remind everybody of what that case is involved, because it's one of the many Trump cases. This is the criminal case involving classified government documents that Trump had taken to his Mar-a-Lago estate after he was no longer president.
这倒是个好消息。好的，那我们现在转向那极其漫长的一周里另一个重大的法律新闻——坎农法官决定驳回针对特朗普在佛罗里达州刑事案件的起诉书。现在，我觉得我们应该提醒大家注意这个案件究竟涉及什么，因为它是特朗普众多案件之一。这是一起涉及涉密政府文件的刑事案件，特朗普在卸任总统后将这些文件带到了他的海湖庄园。
And remember, Trump was not legally permitted to retain these documents. And you probably remember the FBI search of Mar-a-Lago in 2022. That was a big headline. Yeah. Now, Trump had announced just two months before that search that he had been indicted by a federal grand jury for retaining the classified documents. And the indictment charged him with something like 37 separate counts of violating federal criminal law. And a later indictment added some additional charges in that case too.
请记住，特朗普在法律上是不被允许保留这些文件的。你可能还记得联邦调查局（FBI）2022年对海湖庄园的搜查。那是个重大新闻。是的。就在那次搜查两个月前，特朗普曾宣布他遭到联邦大陪审团起诉，罪名是保留涉密文件。起诉书指控他犯有大约37项违反联邦刑法的独立罪名。随后的起诉书还在该案中增加了一些额外的指控。
Now the reason why this became a serious criminal case was because the government charges Trump, not just with holding on to documents he shouldn't have, but willfully retaining these very sensitive documents. So this is not just a case of, you know, whoops, I'm sorry, I didn't realize I had these documents. You can have them back. The reason why this is a criminal case is because allegedly he knew he shouldn't have had them. He claimed not to have any more after he turns them over.
这之所以成为一起严重的刑事案件，是因为政府对特朗普的指控不仅是持有他不应持有的文件，而是蓄意保留这些高度敏感的文件。所以这不仅仅是一起“哎呀，对不起，我没意识到我有这些文件，你们拿回去吧”的案件。这之所以是一起刑事案件，是因为据称他明知自己不该拥有这些文件。他在交出文件后声称自己没有任何文件了。
And then he hindered or obstructed the government's attempts to try and look for those documents. That's certainly something you're not supposed to do. Yeah. Now, after Trump announced in November of 2022 that he was going to run for president again, Attorney General Merrick Garland appointed Jack Smith as a special counsel.
然后他阻挠或妨碍了政府试图搜寻这些文件的企图。这绝对是明令禁止的行径。是的。在特朗普于2022年11月宣布将再次竞选总统后，司法部长梅里克·加兰任命杰克·史密斯为特别检察官。
So what exactly does a special counsel do in this type of case? Okay, when the Justice Department appoints a special counsel, or sometimes it's called an independent counsel, that means that the Justice Department senses that there's at least a perceived need to hire a federal prosecutor who isn't within the usual hierarchy of the Justice Department, often because there's some politically sensitive
那么，特别检察官在这种类型的案件中究竟做什么？好的，当司法部任命特别检察官（有时被称为独立检察官）时，这意味着司法部察觉到至少有必要聘请一位不属于司法部通常层级体系的联邦检察官，通常是因为涉及某些政治敏感案件——
or controversial case. So an independent or a special counsel is not directly overseen by the attorney general. I mean, there is some oversight, but the idea here is that a special counsel enjoys some independence about how to conduct an investigation. Yeah. And we've had special federal prosecutors appointed for decades. Do you remember the Watergate Tapes case from 1974? I do, yeah.
或充满争议的案件。因此，独立检察官或特别检察官不受司法部长的直接监督。我的意思是，确实存在一定的监督，但这里的核心理念是，特别检察官在如何开展调查方面享有一定的独立性。是的。几十年来，我们一直被任命有联邦特别检察官。你还记得1974年的“水门事件录音带案”吗？记得，是的。
Yeah, and we've talked about that Supreme Court decision before. Totally, yeah. But actually, we only focused on one important aspect of it, and that was the court's recognition of what's called executive privilege. And that's the idea that presidents can keep some communications secret. But in the very same case, the Supreme Court also had to address Nixon's claim that the Supreme Court didn't have any authority to get involved in the case at all. Because in that case, he had refused to turn over the tapes to Leon
是的，我们以前讨论过那个最高法院的判决。完全记得，是的。但实际上，我们当时只关注了其中一个重要方面，那就是法院对所谓“行政特权”的承认。这个概念指的是总统可以对某些通信内容保密。但在同一个案件中，最高法院还不得不处理理查德·尼克松的一项主张，即最高法院根本无权介入此案。因为在该案中，他拒绝将录音带交出给——
Jaworski, the special prosecutor who had been appointed by then acting Attorney General Robert Bork. So this part is important because the court ultimately rejected Nixon's argument. The court said, we can look at this case. And in doing so, the Supreme Court explained that Congress, by passing a series of federal statutes gave the attorney general the power to investigate crimes. Not only that, Congress gave the attorney general the power to appoint what it called subordinate officers to help do that. And the court interprets this as meaning that's why there can be a special prosecutor. And so ever since that time, which is 50 years ago now, this part of the Nixon case that the
当时代理司法部长罗伯特·博克（Robert Bork）任命的特别检察官利昂·贾沃斯基（Leon Jaworski）。所以这一部分很重要，因为法院最终驳回了尼克松的论点。法院表示，我们有权审理此案。在审理过程中，最高法院解释说，国会通过颁布一系列联邦成文法，赋予了司法部长调查犯罪的权力。不仅如此，国会还赋予了司法部长任命所谓下属官员来协助完成这项工作的权力。法院将此解读为：这就是为什么可以设立特别检察官的原因。因此，自那时起——也就是现在的50年前——尼克松案中关于司法部长可以任命特别检察官这一部分，已被广泛接受。几十年来，我们有过很多特别检察官，比如在里根政府时期调查“伊朗-反对派丑闻”的特别检察官，还有罗伯特·米勒，还记得他吗？是的，当然。
attorney general can appoint special prosecutors has been widely accepted. We've had a lot of special counsels over the decades, like the special counsel who investigated the Iran-Contra affair during the Reagan administration and Robert Mueller, remember him? Yeah, sure. That's right. So Mueller, of course, was a special counsel appointed by acting attorney general Rod Rosenstein. And so since 1999, federal special counsels have been appointed under a set of federal regulations which are implementing federal statutes.
没错。当然，米勒是由时任代理司法部长罗德·罗森斯坦任命的特别检察官。因此，自1999年以来，联邦特别检察官一直根据一套落实联邦成文法的联邦法规被任命。
And those regulations say that the attorney general can supervise a special counsel, but the special counsel has a lot of independence. And independence is the entire point of this kind of job. Right. So all of this put together means that the idea of independent federal special councils being legitimate and lawful and constitutional has been widely accepted by lawyers, judges, Congress, and literally decades of historical experience, unless you're Eileen Cannon.
这些法规规定，司法部长可以监督特别检察官，但特别检察官拥有很大的独立性。而独立性正是这类职务的核心意义所在。没错。所有这一切组合起来意味着，独立的联邦特别检察官是合法、合规且合宪的概念，这一观点已被律师、法官、国会以及长达数十年的历史经验广泛接受，除非你是艾琳·坎农。
With that, we can return to Trump and the classified documents case. Trump argued that Jack Smith's appointment as special counsel was not just illegal, but it was unconstitutional. And on July 15, Judge Cannon agreed with Trump and actually ordered that the charges against Trump be completely dismissed. So how did she explain herself in this case,
有了这些背景，我们可以回到特朗普和涉密文件案。特朗普辩称，杰克·史密斯作为特别检察官的任命不仅不合法，而且违宪。7月15日，坎农法官认同了特朗普的观点，并下令彻底驳回针对特朗普的指控。那么她是如何在该案中为自己辩解的呢？
sort of contradicting 50 years of precedent? Well, Cannon decided that Garland's appointment of Smith was unconstitutional because it was a violation of Article II, Section 2, Clause 2 of the Constitution, also known as the Appointments Clause. So Roman, why don't I have you read the clause? Okay, here we go. The President shall nominate and by and with the advice
这简直是对50年判例的公然违背。坎农裁定，加兰对史密斯的任命违宪，因为它违反了宪法第二条第二款第二句，也就是所谓的“官员任命条款”。那么罗曼，要不由你来朗读一下这个条款吧？好的，开始。总统经参议院的建议和同意，有权任命大使、公使及领事、最高法院的法官，以及所有其任命未在本宪法中其他地方作其他规定、且其职务经法律设立的合众国其他官员；
and consent of the Senate shall appoint officers of the United States whose appointments are not herein otherwise provided for and which shall be established by law. But the Congress may by law vest the appointment of such inferior officers as they think proper in the president alone, in the courts of law, or in the heads of departments." Danielle Pletka Another one of those perfectly clear parts of the Constitution, right? It's really hard to understand. So the Supreme Court has discussed this clause a lot, and you can tell it can be pretty confusing. But here's a simple way to think about it.
但国会可以通过法律，将下级官员的任命权根据其认为适当的情况，授予总统本人、法院或各部部长。丹尼尔·普莱特卡：又是一个字面意思极其清晰的宪法条款，对吧？真的很难理解。因此，最高法院对这个条款进行过大量讨论，你可以看出它可能会让人相当困惑。但这里有一个简单的思考方式。
So if you think of all of the people who work in the federal government, there are a small group of positions that are considered officers of the United States. And I mean, relatively speaking, we're still talking about hundreds of people, but it's not close to the many, many thousands more who work for the federal government. But these are the officers that are referred to in the appointments clause. Officers can be principal officers or so-called inferior officers. And the default rule here is that the president has the power to appoint principal officers who are then confirmed by the Senate. So if you think about the president's cabinet, that's how they
如果你把联邦政府中所有的工作人员都考虑在内，其中只有一小部分职位被视为合众国官员。我的意思是，相对而言，我们讨论的仍然是数百人，但与为联邦政府工作的成千上万的其他人员相比，这只是少数。但这些正是任命条款中所指的官员。官员可以分为主要官员或所谓的下级官员。这里的默认规则是，总统有权任命主要官员，然后由参议院予以确认。所以如果你想想总统的内阁成员，他们就是这样获得职位的。
get their jobs. But with inferior officers, Congress has the option to decide to give that appointment power to somebody else. So in theory, Attorney General Garland could be that someone else, the head of department that you just referred to in the Appointments Clause. Jack Smith said that he was an inferior officer appointed by Garland, the head of a department. And Smith also pointed to the 1999 federal regulations, the federal statutes cited by the Supreme Court in the Nixon case, the Nixon case itself, and the general idea that, look, everybody has assumed for a long time that special counsels can be constitutionally appointed. This is where Cannon deviated from everyone else. Cannon said, well, look, none of the federal statutes
但对于下级官员，国会有权选择将任命权授予其他人。所以在理论上，司法部长加兰就可以是那“其他人”，也就是你刚刚在任命条款中提到的“各部部长”。杰克·史密斯声称自己是由部门负责人加兰任命的下级官员。史密斯还指出了1999年的联邦法规、最高法院在尼克松案中引用的联邦成文法、尼克松案本身，以及这样一种普遍观点：长期以来，所有人都认为特别检察官的任命是合宪的。正是这一点让坎农偏离了所有人。坎农说，嗯，瞧，没有任何联邦成文法或联邦法规明确说出那些神奇的字眼：“国会授予司法部长任命特别检察官的权力”。从技术上讲，这确实是真的。并没有这样字面意义的句子。但话说回来，如果你把所有的联邦法律综合起来看，再加上最高法院在尼克松案中的言论，再加上一堆对尼克松案进行了解释的下级法院判例——
or federal regulations specifically say the magic words, Congress gives the attorney general the power to appoint a special counsel. And technically that's true. There isn't a literal sentence like that. But again, if you read all of the federal law put together, plus what the Supreme Court said in the Nixon case, plus a bunch of lower court cases
再加上数十年的历史经验，法院对尼克松案的解释，你就会得出一个相当令人信服的结论：杰克·史密斯是合法的，他的职位是合规的。所以你可能会想，等一下，怎么能忽视最高法院说过的话呢？最高法院难道没有说过这种任命是合宪的吗？好吧，坎农用一种非常奇怪的方式绕过了这一点。
that have interpreted the Nixon case, again, plus decades of historical experience court cases that have interpreted the Nixon case, again, plus decades of historical experience, there's a pretty convincing case that Jack Smith is legal, that his position is lawful. So then you might think, well, wait a minute, how can you ignore what the Supreme Court said, right? Didn't the Supreme Court say that this kind of appointment is constitutional? Well, Cannon gets around this in a very strange way.
她声称，最高法院当时只是顺便提到国会似乎赋予了司法部长任命特别检察官的权力。他们并没有真正对该问题作出裁决，所以我可以忽略它。因此，坎农的推理逻辑大致如下：国会本可以赋予司法部长加兰任命杰克·史密斯的权力，那样的话将是合宪的。但由于坎农法官判定，没有任何联邦法律说出那些允许司法部长任命特别检察官的神奇字眼，因此杰克·史密斯的职位是不合法的，因为你刚刚读过的任命条款规定，国会必须“通过法律”做到这一点，而她说根本没有这样的法律。换句话说，她那93页的意见书归结到底是什么意思？这意味着必须有某种联邦成文法授权司法部长加兰任命史密斯，但实际上并没有。所以这意味着他的任命违反了宪法的任命条款。
She says that the Supreme Court was just kind of mentioning that Congress seemed to have given the attorney general the power to appoint special counsels. They weren't actually deciding that issue, so I can ignore it. And so Cannon's reasoning runs like this. Congress could have given Attorney General Garland the power to appoint Jack Smith, then that would have been constitutional. But because Judge Cannon decides
因此，坎农走了一条几乎无人走过的路，但该裁决之所以如此意义重大，是因为她的推理最终导向了这样的结果：由于杰克·史密斯的任命不合法，她下令政府撤销在涉密文件案中对特朗普的指控。就这么简单。经历了这么长时间，经历了联邦调查局的调查，经历了某些相当确凿的证据的曝光，经历了大陪审团发布起诉书之后。
that there is no federal law that says the magic words allowing the Attorney General to appoint a special counsel, Jack Smith's position is not legal because the Appointments Clause that you just read says that Congress must have done this quote by law and there is no law she says. So in other words, what is her 93 page opinion boiled down to? It means that there has to be some federal statute that authorized Attorney General Garland to appoint Smith, but there isn't. So that means that his appointment violates the constitution's appointment clause.
这才是最令人震惊的部分。她似乎心安理得地宣布不再进行起诉。那么她的这个想法是从哪儿来的呢？在它如此违背现实生活经验、违背宪法以及人们对这类事情的种种认知的的情况下，她怎么能说出这样的话呢？首先，我们知道在涉密文件案中，坎农法官特别倾向于给予特朗普所有的疑罪从无（疑点利益）。不仅仅是在这个问题上，在其他问题上也是如此。
So Cannon goes in a direction that really nobody else has, but the reason the decision is so significant is that what she decides is the result of her reasoning because Jack Smith was not lawfully appointed. She orders the government to drop the charges against Trump in the classified documents case. Period. After all of this time, after the FBI investigation, after the revelation of some pretty damning evidence, after the grand jury issues an indictment.
但实际上还有一个更具体的原因。这源于你和我上次讨论过的豁免权案。好的。当然，在那起案件中，最高法院为美国总统确立了这种非常非常宽泛的豁免权。但大法官克拉伦斯·托马斯（Clarence Thomas）发表了一份协同意见。他不仅认为给予任何总统如此广泛的豁免权是正确的，他还说：我还有话要讲。而他要讲的另一件事是，顺便说一句，我认为特别检察官是违宪的。当然没有人问过他，但这正是他想要表达的。托马斯在单独的意见书中表示，如果对特朗普史无前例的起诉（这是他的原话）要继续下去，正如他所说的那样，它必须由得到美国人民正式授权的人来执行。而他认为杰克·史密斯并非这样的人。
That's the shocking part. She appears to be comfortable with saying no more prosecution. So where does she get this idea? How could she say this when it's so contrary to actual lived experience and constitution and every other way people think about this type of thing? Well number one, we know in the classified documents case that Judge Cannon has been particularly susceptible to giving Trump every benefit of the doubt. And not just in this issue, but in others.
所以从本质上讲，坎农法官接过了这一指控并付诸实践。她在自己的意见书中数次引用了托马斯在豁免权案中的意见。这就是现状。涉密文件案此刻已经宣告死亡。特朗普继续当着一个幸运、幸运、极其幸运的刑事被告，至少在联邦法院是这样。
But there's actually an even more specific reason. And that comes from the immunity case that you and I talked about last time. OK. Now, of course, in that case, the Supreme Court recognized this very, very generous immunity for a president of the United States. But Justice Clarence Thomas had a concurring opinion. Not only did he
但实际上还有一个更具体的原因。这来自于你我上次谈到的豁免权案。好的。当然，在那起案件中，最高法院为美国总统承认了这种非常非常宽泛的豁免权。但大法官克拉伦斯·托马斯有一份协同意见书。他不仅
think that that was right about giving any president such broad immunity, he said, I have something else to say. And his something else was, by the way, I think special councils are unconstitutional. Granted, nobody asked him, but this is what he wanted to say. Thomas says in his separate opinion that if the unprecedented prosecution of Trump, that's his words, was going to go forward, it must, as he put it, be conducted by someone duly authorized by the American people. And he didn't think Jack Smith was such a person.
认为给予任何总统如此广泛的豁免权是正确的，他还说，我还有话要说。他要说的另一件事是，顺便说一句，我认为特别检察官是违宪的。诚然，没有人问过他，但这正是他想说的。托马斯在他的独立意见中表示，如果对特朗普史无前例的起诉（这是他的原话）要继续下去，正如他所说，必须由美国人民正式授权的人来执行。而且他认为杰克·史密斯并非这样的人。
So essentially, Judge Cannon took up that charge and ran with it. She actually cites Thomas's opinion in the immunity case a couple of times in her own opinion. And there you have it. The classified documents case at this moment is dead. Trump continues to be a lucky, lucky, lucky criminal defendant, at least in the federal courts.
所以基本上，卡农法官接过了这个指控并付诸行动。她在自己的意见书中多次引用了托马斯在豁免权案中的意见。事情就是这样。目前，涉密文件案已经终结。特朗普依然是一个非常、非常、非常幸运的刑事被告，至少在联邦法院是这样。
Is there anything to be done when she dismisses it? Is that the end of it? It's not the end of it. So Smith has already decided to appeal the case. He'll be appealing the dismissal of the indictment and he'll be going up to the federal appeals court in the region. That's the 11th circuit. Now there's some possibility that things will go in Smith's favor because the 11th circuit has reversed judge Cannon in the classified documents case before. And the odds are pretty good that they might reverse her, again, because Cannon is going against the weight of a lot of consensus opinion. But if Smith wins,
当她驳回案子时，有什么办法吗？这就结束了吗？并没有结束。因此，史密斯已经决定对该案提起上诉。他将对驳回起诉的决定提起上诉，并上诉至该地区的联邦上诉法院，也就是第十一巡回法院。现在有一种可能性，事情会朝着对史密斯有利的方向发展，因为第十一巡回法院以前曾在涉密文件案中推翻过坎农法官的裁决。他们再次推翻她的裁决的可能性相当大，因为坎农的裁决违背了大量的一致意见。但是，如果史密斯赢了，
of course, that might not be the end of the case either, and it could go up to the Supreme Court. And Candace's decision has had another totally unexpected effect. You might be aware that President Biden's son Hunter was accused of getting involved in some illegal gun registration or lack of registration and some tax evasion charges. Do you remember what happened to that investigation? I mean, he was found guilty. Yeah. And what kind of prosecutor prosecuted his case? Was it a special prosecutor?
当然，这可能也不是案件的终点，案件甚至可能会上诉到最高法院。坎农的决定还产生了另一个完全意料之外的影响。大家可能知道，拜登总统的儿子亨特被指控参与一些非法的枪支登记或缺乏登记，以及一些逃税指控。你还记得那项调查是怎么回事吗？我的意思是，他被判有罪了。是的。什么样的检察官起诉了他的案子？是特别检察官吗？
Independent? Yes, it was. It was a special counsel appointed by Attorney General Garland. Again, why? To avoid the appearance of a conflict, since he is, of course, the attorney general in the Biden administration. But of course, the attorney general in the Biden administration.
独立的？是的，是的。那是司法部长加兰任命的特别检察官。还是那句话，为什么？为了避免利益冲突的嫌疑，因为他毕竟是拜登政府的司法部长。不过当然，拜登政府的司法部长。
But of course, you know, the law doesn't always work just for one kind of person or one kind of party. And so understandably, Hunter Biden now has filed legal papers saying, look, if Jack Smith's position is unlawful, so too are the special prosecutors in my case, dismiss my pending criminal case, and reverse my conviction. Wow. What a weird side effect. Ha ha ha. Yep.
但当然，你知道，法律并不总是只为某一种人或某一个政党服务。因此，可以理解的是，亨特·拜登现在已经提交了法律文件，大意是：看，如果杰克·史密斯的职位是不合法的，那我案子里的特别检察官也是不合法的，请驳回我未决的刑事案件，并撤销对我的定罪。哇。多么奇怪的副作用。哈哈。是的。
So how does this decision affect any of the other cases that are pending against Trump? That's a great question. So in the state cases, the one where Trump has had a conviction already in New York and then a pending criminal case in Georgia, there's no application at all. Yeah. So we're talking about federal special prosecutors or independent counsel. So there won't be any effect. Now, it might seem like, look, doesn't this have the same effect in the federal election interference case? For now,
那么，这项决定如何影响针对特朗普的其他未决案件呢？这是一个很好的问题。因此，在州法院的案件中，即特朗普已经在纽约被定罪以及在佐治亚州有一个未决刑事案件的案件中，这个裁决完全不适用。是的。所以我们讨论的是联邦特别检察官或独立法律顾问。因此不会有任何影响。现在，这似乎会让人觉得，看，这难道不会对联邦选举干涉案产生同样的影响吗？目前，
the answer is no, because as I mentioned, there's been a widespread consensus since the Nixon case that special counsels are legitimate and constitutional. And in fact, in the federal appeals court that covers Judge Chutkin's case, that's the judge in the election interference case, that court had already decided before that it would reject any challenges saying, look, a special counsel is unconstitutional.
答案是否定的，因为正如我所提到的，自尼克松案以来，人们普遍达成共识，即特别检察官是合法且符合宪法的。事实上，在管辖丘特金法官案件的联邦上诉法院——也就是选举干涉案的法官——该法院之前就已经做出决定，将拒绝任何声称特别检察官违宪的异议。
So in his case, in the District of Columbia, the applicable law means that his special prosecutor is lawful so far. Because of course, Judge Eileen Cannon is only a federal trial court judge in the 11th Circuit. So what she says doesn't directly affect what happens in the Court of Appeals in the District of Columbia. Now, that's the case for now.
因此，在他的案件中，在哥伦比亚特区，适用的法律意味着他的特别检察官目前是合法的。因为当然，艾琳·坎农法官只是第十一巡回法院的一名联邦初审法院法官。所以她说的话并不直接影响哥伦比亚特区上诉法院发生的事情。不过，目前情况是这样的。
Of course, if we fast forward, if the Supreme Court, for example, were to take up this case, somehow Justice Thomas convinces some of his colleagues to take another look at the lawfulness or the constitutionality of a special prosecutor. That could lead to yet another Supreme Court case, which of course would have national effect. But we're certainly not there yet. And as far as Judge Eileen Cannon's opinion is concerned, it only affects Trump's classified documents case in Mar-a-Lago.
当然，如果我们快进到未来，如果最高法院例如决定审理此案，托马斯大法官不知何故说服了一些同事重新审视特别检察官的合法性或违宪性。这可能会导致又一个最高法院案件，这当然会产生全国性的影响。但我们肯定还没到那一步。就艾琳·坎农法官的意见而言，它只影响特朗普在海湖庄园的涉密文件案。
And in fact, Cannon made a statement in her opinion, which may or may not have any really important effect for now, which she says, this is only applicable to this case in particular. And we know already that's not true, since Hunter Biden says, hey, what about me? I'd like my case dismissed too, and look out for other people in similar situations saying the same thing. Yeah. So is there any recourse when it comes to sort of questioning Cannon's judgment here
事实上，坎农在她的意见中发表了一份声明，现在看来这可能具有也可能不具有真正重要的影响，她说，这仅适用于这个特定的案件。我们已经知道这不是真的，因为亨特·拜登说，嘿，那我呢？我也想让我的案子被驳回，而且要小心其他处境相似的人也会说同样的话。是的。那么，当谈到对坎农这里的判断提出质疑时，有什么救济途径吗？
and like what could be possibly done? Well, there is some speculation that Jack Smith might ask now that the case be reassigned to a different federal judge if the case survives. There's some risk with that because if his request is denied, then he ends up with a really pissed off Judge Cannon in this case. That would be bad. Now so far, Jack Smith might be able to point out to different things that have happened in the actual case to say, look, her actions seem to be very, very biased in favor of Trump
比如可能可以做些什么？嗯，有一些猜测认为，如果案件得以存续，杰克·史密斯现在可能会要求将案件重新分配给另一位联邦法官。这样做有一些风险，因为如果他的请求被拒绝，那么他最终在这个案子里就会面对一个非常生气的坎农法官。那可就糟了。目前，杰克·史密斯或许能够指出实际案件中发生的各种事情，以表明：看，她的行为似乎非常非常偏袒特朗普，
and very biased against the government. So that would be the best case scenario. Judge Cannon was in fact appointed by Trump, but that's probably not a good move by Jack Smith because it's not always the case that just because a judge has been appointed by a president of a particular party, they always side with issues and decisions that seem to favor one party or one side rather than the other.
并且非常偏向于不利于政府的一方。所以那将是最好的情况。坎农法官实际上是被特朗普任命的，但这可能不是杰克·史密斯的好举动，因为并不是说只要一个法官是由某个特定政党的总统任命的，他们就总是站在似乎偏袒某一方或某个阵营的立场和决定上。
So it would be much more likely that Smith would say, look, look at the actual things she's decided in this case. Mm-hmm. Well, it's fascinating stuff, and there's just so much going on, so I'm glad that we're meeting every two weeks. And let's just hope that maybe in the next sort of interregnum between the times we talk, a little less news happens.
因此，更有可能的情况是，史密斯会说，瞧，看看她在这个案件中实际做出的裁决。嗯哼。好吧，这些内容太迷人了，有太多事情正在发生，所以我很高兴我们每两周见面一次。让我们希望，在我们对话的下一个间歇期里，发生的新闻能少一点。
Just for both of our sake and the country's sake. Yeah, let's hope for some boring times. Thanks. Thanks, let's hope for some boring times. Thanks. Thanks, Roman. This show is produced by Elizabeth Jo, Isabel Angel, and me, Roman Mars. It's mixed by Ezekh Ben-Amad Fareed. Our executive producer is Cathy Tu. You can find us online at LearnConLaw.com. All the music and what Roman Mars can learn about Con Law is provided by Doomtree Records, the
为了我们俩好，也为了国家好。是的，让我们期盼一段平静的时光。谢谢。谢谢，让我们期盼平静的时光。谢谢。谢谢，罗曼。本节目由伊丽莎白·乔、伊莎贝尔·安杰尔和我罗曼·马尔斯制作。由埃泽赫·本-阿马德·法里德混音。我们的执行制片人是凯茜·图。您可以在 LearnConLaw.com 上在线找到我们。所有的音乐以及罗曼·马尔斯关于宪法法能学到的一切都由 Doomtree Records 提供，这是一个
Midwest hip hop collective. You can find out more about Doomtree Records, get merch, and learn about who's on tour at Doomtree.net. We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
中西部嘻哈集体。您可以在 Doomtree.net 上了解更多关于 Doomtree Records 的信息、购买周边商品并了解谁在巡演。我们是 Stitcher 和 SiriusXM 播客家族的一部分。该集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。